bonsoir mylvada mois alors on va essayer
de comprendre cette affaire
vous l'avez dit le suspect avait déjà
tué sa mère en 2016 alors comment ça a
pu se reproduire aujourd'hui vient nous
avons contacté le procureur de la
république de mâcon en charge de cette
affaire qui a pu nous a éclairé le 17
février 2016 clément guérin tue sa mère
il est appréhendé et trois jours plus
tard mis en examen pour assassinat la
première question que l'on se pose que
l'instruction se pose dans ce type
d'affaires et bien c'est la
responsabilité du justus est très tôt
son comportement et ses propos font
douter le juge se pose alors la question
de savoir de quoi souffre clément guérin
et bien il s'agirait d'abolition du
discernement à savoir que par moments il
perd pleine conscience de ses faits et
gestes il est également diagnostiqué
schizophrène en novembre 2010 est la
chambre d'instruction va ordonner son
placement en hospitalisation sous
contrainte à sevrey près de châlons un
an plus tard en décembre 2018 une
nouvelle expertise psychiatrique et
mener ses conclusions aurait alors
permis au juge des liberté de décider de
mettre fin à son internement c'était il
ya quatre mois marie est alors clément
guérin donc c'est le suspect il a un
profil bien particulier
oui les jeunes clément guérin il n'a que
25 ans il avait 22 ans quand il a tué sa
mère il est donc diagnostiqué
schizophrène et des habitants de romenay
que nous avons pu rencontrer toute la
journée nous ont indiqué qu'à l'époque
des faits en 2016 il était donc plâtrier
de formation mais sans emploi chez ses
parents il était en proie aussi et
surtout à une addiction forte à la
drogue selon eux encore une fois après
avoir tué sa mère il avait manifesté son
intention de recommencer et armé même
déjà à l'époque désigner des proches qui
le souhaitaient tuer sa sortie de
l'hôpital en décembre dernier un tout
récemment avait été pourtant réclamé
aussi en partie par son père qui est
devenu sa victime ce matin
merci beaucoup mylvada mois